[Music]
when the doctors diagnosed me they told
me that I wouldn't be able to clothe
myself or feed myself that I would need
assistance for pretty much everything I
did
my body is more than just a sack it's
it's actually an instrument to do great
things with and I've been a professional
dancer for six years
[Music]
I'm Geron Herman and I have Himalaya
cerebral palsy cerebral palsy is a
neuromuscular disorder that affects
message is going to feed muscles in your
body so the result is involuntary motion
and spasticity hemiplegia
refers to me because it affects only the
left side of my body
[Music]
hi Lansky dance is a company that
integrates people with disabilities
I've always been an advocate for those
two pursuing the antithesis of the thing
that is their limitation why dance
primarily because of the physical
diagnosis I was given my body is the
instrument and if I'm a disabled person
and my body is the instrument it's it's
pretty pretty audacious as I've been
told my arabesque is crazy but it's for
my left side and it sounds from my left
leg shooting up to the air and my
balance is based on my right side being
the main impetus for all for my control
so that these things that were perceived
as negatives are now folded into the
choreography when I am in the moment and
I'm dancing I feel this calm that I've
got this everything is working together
and then some
dance has relieved me a stereotype that
is placed on people with disabilities
[Music]
practice here but everybody beginning of
the movement of a trap at the beginning
the number of - oh moody Jaron brown
they come in da da da da da
unfortunately get a little movement
right
he is now a little bit of a little a
Mandela stop is it empathy reverse pipe
and the pirate Kalamandalam review mark
nanotech has her leadership in Havana
control Ian with the signal para la
practica happiness isn't a little
irritated at each other with a Fenian
granular cannula angie happy named
Walker control Livadia Vania hiding
relationally lala haria VA para para
entender salty Avenue
another near look at to Muslim Colonel
in a moment but I'm a little cardinal de
brazza a True Blood Hana other wonder
than jana khun danai practices number i
each toughness is easily began like this
ordinary returning evil tapered again
we're in a book tape of the universe
elevator we're under a hundred or so
tall with a pot holder
Lucas a legal on island starting model a
and the G with I was on a very opportune
thing here nomicon sankalpa can patata
versa yg3
ecology wanna turn a bizarre acerca de
votre amorini burn angle NIDA manicure
angle of samuel-kun you through there
near another
about 30 item e38 regalia the marine
lord samskaara dahana shared he para
Maria I trow like a level editor but in
del amor a leader on you and blood on
the rector and I cut earlier and the
manager said ìdo cause I really curate
our particular develop a poor in an
energy wisdom can really give order to
Ibaka every in the world and the gu zong
Han curriculum
[Music]
dance is something that comes in every
last one of us from birth what we do is
take that and give them an opportunity
to personalize it and then it empowers
us to dance at this level
[Music]
my name is Melvin Mitchell Aiko and I'm
the founder of Northwest tap connection
our mission is to close the gap for
underserved communities with an emphasis
on children of color and really just
open that door for young people who
would not be able to have accessibility
to the arts because of cost to have
those opportunities that are enriching
when I started off with staff I was
working for the set up police department
and my goal was that children that I got
to see on a weekly basis I would never
see across my desk tap dancing is the
foundation of our organization I strive
to make sure that children understand
that it is a dance form that comes out
of black culture it comes out of protest
and we have to appreciate it embrace it
and protect it as we pass it down
Northwest tab is a race and social
justice oriented studio and being an
african-american male I don't think had
I danced at another studio that I would
have been surrounded by so many fellow
african-americans and I feel like that
has given me the confidence to feel
comfortable in my skin and normal
everyday life I don't really like
talking very much but when it comes to
dancing I am able to just communicate in
a way that touches people rather than
what they're just hearing my feelings as
I watched young people's and there is
this sense of pride for the work that
they do but then at the same time
there's this sense of fear and trouble
for me how much longer will we continue
with this struggle dance is such an
empowering tool we are communities of
many colors many genders identifications
but we are one through these children
that dance we're creating a new tomorrow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
my way of expressing myself has always
been physical my mom told me was like
since I was little it's like if I would
be angry or happy or whatever you would
see it in in my body language for me
having a new way of challenging my buddy
a new way of pushing the limits of my
what my body can do that was the thing
that really got me hooked in flying
my name is Inga DITA and I'm a dancer
and a world champion indoor skydiver
I started dancing when I was three years
old and as long as I remember I've been
dancing when indoor skydiving came along
I found something for the first time
that I was more passionate about than I
ever was about dancing suddenly I
realized like I've just found a new way
of dancing it's just on a different kind
of dance floor the discipline that I
compete in is called freestyle but when
I'm speaking about my flying overall I
prefer to use the term air dancing
because it's not just about competing
and that set discipline it's about
creating something new exploring the
limits of what we can do in flying and I
would like to take flying from being a
sport towards being a form of performing
arts flying for sure is way harder than
it looks like the wind speeds can go up
to 180 miles an hour you have to be
strong you have to be flexible a lot of
the body positions look easy but they
actually require a lot to perform them
nicely so a split for example it might
look like I'm just resting in in that
flexible body position but I'm actually
all the time pushing against the airflow
to have control
[Music]
I don't always like the use of the word
talented because it makes it sounds like
only if you have that talent before you
even start flying you're gonna get good
I've always been like a hard worker
myself so if I really want to get good
at something I'm gonna do whatever it
takes it just depends on how much you
want it
you
[Music]